up next we got Michelle root izinski oh
yes yeah for sure shorty last name I'm a
huge fan of the show you're both so
[ __ ] hilarious I appreciate you both
so much
watch me Youth you you're so charming
you still hangs on such a good heart and
I appreciate everything you do thank you
so much he's mean it's [ __ ] so to make
up for your well place you can honestly
only choose one it was saying aren't you
talking about that well let's see him
once again you can only choose one so if
you could would you rather be a gang
gang buzz buzz buzz buzz buzz lightyear
huh buzz it up buzz be a long time in my
pants bro oh yeah welcome to the lava
section waterpark of my pants now girl
what's up wants a couple nuts full of
love ah you got me Six Flags in my pants
ah tits are asked here's the thing
people at this the yeah tell me the
thing you're reading here's this gonna
be bro it's gonna be unhelpful no it's
not unhelpful here's the thing brah yeah
what is the rate for this we've been
waiting mm-hmm you don't have to choose
this day and age there's girls with
front and back they're called
Latinas or black girls only white girls
like assert it's pick an ethnic girl
they're both no I'm saying but sometimes
if you get a go with both they get real
there's a lot more the potential for
violence is stronger I like being on my
toes you ant hell yeah I got head
movement the other thing is there's
nothing worse than a girl with a flat
ass you take a fat ass all day with some
itty-bitty mosquito titties yeah but if
you got those big hitters in the front
you get that flat ass in the back that
ain't hit daddy that ain't it dude we
had a girl when I was young
be is it 12 huh
bro I feel bad for him she probably
weighed 77 and maybe 78 pounds somewhere
in there tits
bro 36 pounds of tits sounds like a
movie 40 pounds 20 but it's her brother
her little brother used to get in front
of him put both tits on his shoulders
you let him do like Deb's and like squat
with it notice like hold him that's a
good brother
yeah but yeah man and she had a very
straight parallel you know just straight
figure yeah that's the bummer the we had
a girls seem soon it was almost like God
like sometime when she was gestating or
whatever whenever she was being made in
the womb that a lot of her ass got
lonely and went to be tits
yeah we've got that flat a syndrome yeah
Ivan look I don't know if that's it the
thing is we had a girl in 7th grade name
was Danielle and she had the biggest
tits in the world only like the darker
boys they only like the dark skin yeah I
was more of her homey do i that i dem
gonna turn science oh yeah bro Danny
let's take this big tip oh yeah shout in
the back mr. McGregor's only growing yam
do you feel me
[ __ ] welcome to yam gana Stan yeah
I'm bill baby mama's sweet patate um I
like more I think like you're more
well-rounded or you like though like the
overbearing watermelons in the front I
like us some ass I think you know I like
some day I like a you know kind of I
don't mind a thick I asked a little bit
of desert fat on it you know I don't
like some of you get that loose loose
fat it can be kind of erroneous but if
you get some of the Kardashians have
that desert fat and you get some of that
desert fat it's kind of yes it's kind of
like it's uh like there's meat in there
somewhere I feel I like that
WorldStarHipHop
oh god there's a [ __ ] involved with all
that oh my god you can get guns on there
they'll make it rain with some guns but
whatever dude mix it up deal
yeah I guess so man anyway this tip
magnet trying to get to you oh yeah I
think Shirley
you got them tits you know what Congrats
yeah and congrats to you see me it's on
the real ones man they're hard to find
these days oh wow oh and the crazy so
you see some of these plastic ones it's
like somebody ordered a bounce house for
the kids you know you know I'm not mad
at one lady she had on a necklace it
what could even set on her chest that it
was so bouncy you know I'm not mad at it
was yeah but sometimes you see somebody
they installed them wrong and sold them
way up here by their clavicles you know
you're like what I don't want
yeah it just seemed like two big-ass
[ __ ] tonsils bro to you know two
tumors on her neck no not tumors like
tonsils dude anyways I like hurt freak
they're her real titties they're cool
man yeah I think you're cool where you
see it I think Russian la man look if
the world's end and I'm gonna be right
up next to you bottom tits so good to
see you huh
thank you be well in Dallas y'all an ass
man you ask for tips look you don't have
to pick her question was a sort it's to
our nineteen you'll have to pick get you
an ethnic girl go I say both ass and
tits so and if you girl doesn't have
tits you could also just spin them
around and draw nipples on their ass or
put a little her she put them Tollhouse
morsels on our ass if you want oh nice
or she's thick enough you make her
[ __ ] tricep a titty you know I'm
saying what do you else you got do
back off my broccolini get your life
together
I'm not touching
you